en el que puedes dejarle mensajes.
Y cuando uno llama y le deja mensajes,
en el mensaje de respuesta
se oyen sonidos de ballena y un bip,
que también se parece a sonido de ballena.
Y también reciben una foto de su ballena.
Este es Randolph,
Randolph pertenece a Nico
uno de los primeros niños que llamó;
les pasaré algunos de los mensajes de Nico.
Este es el primer mensaje que recibí de Nico.
(Audio) Nico: Hola, soy Nico.
Soy tu dueño, Randolph. Hola.
Es la primera vez que te hablo,
pronto puedo hablarte otra vez. Adiós.
Mac Barnett: Nico llamó otra vez, como una hora después.
(Risas)
Otro mensaje de Nico.
(Audio) Nico: Hola, Randolph, soy Nico.
No hemos hablado hace mucho tiempo,
te llamé el sábado o domingo,
sí, sábado o domingo,
por eso te llamo otra vez
para saludarte y preguntarte qué estás haciendo ahora,
probablemente te llamaré otra vez
hoy o mañana,
te llamo más tarde. Adiós.
MB: Lo hizo, llamó otra vez ese día.
Dejó 25 mensajes para Randolph
en 4 años.
Allí está todo sobre él,
la abuela que ama,
la abuela que quiere un poco menos...
(Risas)
los crucigramas que hace,
y... les pasaré otro mensaje de Nico.
Mensaje de Navidad de Nico.
[Bip] (Audio) Nico: Hola, Randolph,
siento no haber hablado contigo en tanto tiempo.
He estado muy ocupado,
empecé la escuela,
como sabrás, probablemente,
como eres ballena no lo sabes,
llamo para decirte,
para desearte Feliz Navidad.
Que tengas una buena Navidad,
Adiós Randolph, adiós.
MB: Ese es Nico,
no supe de él en 18 meses,
y hace 2 días dejó un mensaje.
Su voz es totalmente diferente,
puso a su niñera al teléfono,
y ella fue muy amable con Randolph también.
Nico es el mejor lector que podía esperar.
Quisiera que todos emocionalmente
llegasen a ese lugar
con las cosas que creo.
Tengo suerte, los niños como Nico son los mejores lectores,
y merecen las mejores historias que podamos contarles.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)